well it certainly is a good day when
we're talking about new music from you
ladies so a new album yeah tell me about
that okay so we are celebrating 25 years
if you can believe it I can believe it
yeah space well the movies it's always
the same I never know what to wear yeah
it must be really ours for you Victoria
you know Charles decides whether to wear
the little Gucci dress the little Gucci
dress or the little Gucci dress exactly
and the album of course which was the
soundtrack to the movie so it's just
been really fun last year we did a
similar thing called spice the first
album and we kind of go into the
archives and we found some unreleased
stuff and with this album we've also
found some live performances so it's all
remastered and beautifully packaged and
it's just fun to really celebrate and
you know to hear those songs again
[Music]
well you know me and my girlfriends 25
years ago dressed up like the Spice
Girls for Halloween like so many other
girls we loved you all soundtrack of our
lives in a lot of ways so when we hear
new music you know what we want to see
we want to see you guys on stage
together we want to see you guys back
out you know doing this live I am with
you you know we did shows in 2019 we
sadly only managed to do the UK and
Ireland before as we know the world went
crazy and we are constantly talking
about opportunities and getting back out
there and it's just you know it's going
to be a matter of time it's something we
do want to do and I think especially
with all these lovely anniversaries that
we're celebrating so as soon as I have
any news I will let you know so is it
safe to say then it's not if it's when I
like to think so okay you know I really
do we are constantly talking and there
are loads of fun stuff you know there's
loads of bits and pieces that we're
thinking about planning on doing but for
me the ultimate is the shows and I think
because we always had such an incredible
fan base here in the US the tour we did
in 1998 is you know hands down one of
the best moments of my life and I want
to do it again so I think we're most
excited about seeing the real America
every single place I think as well it's
about time we came over here and gave
like our fans a big thank you so we
haven't performed live in America live I
will tease this Mel B hair back up and
put my put my costume back on again let
me tell you I love this right so this is
always a thing I remember about our
American audience
in Europe we often had our fans who were
quite young at the time dressing as
their favorite Spice Girl and then we
came to the us and we had our fans our
younger fans were also the parents yeah
dressing and I just thought it's such a
sense of fun everybody got involved and
I'd love to be back in that environment
[Music]